Jessica is an award winning journalist and critic who writes on gender,
sexuality,
and Culture for the New York Times.
She's covered sexual assaults on campus,
spent time with Hillary Clinton's childhood friends and was the first journalist
to profile Monica Lewinsky and a decade.
She also writes a regular column on digital language.
Jessica's first book,
Feminist Fight Club,
a survival manual for sexist workplace has been hailed as the millennial lean in
by the New York Times and a must read by the Guardian and yes,
she's in a real life fight club.
We're going to get started with a quick video
[inaudible].
I'm glad that you brought up millennials.
Our total marketing reach with millennials has gotten out about 60% of our
overall website visits have also been up about 17% the way that we can actually
change things.
Focus.
You guys read that email?
I think that our primary here,
our total market now range grew by 50% overall website.
Any five
which is really awkward
getting reach up by 16% last year.
The point Amanda,
thank you.
Whew.
Huh.
You know that our goals for Q four are about the roadmap and the diversity and
the progress of our company,
our company.
If it's about anything,
we really represent hashtag progress.
It's really where we draw our core values.
Brittany,
do you mind taking notes on this?
So we,
so we get everything.
We get everything down.
Oh,
you know,
it was really great at taking notes.
Is Is Josh?
Wait,
what?
Fake telogy.
Hey Pj,
we did you talk about the quarterly sales report.
Your team is down about 60% from last quarter.
Yeah,
just
guys,
guys
nailed right in the balls from that was hilarious.
So Bj,
this is a huge deal.
I have to take this as CEO.
You understand?
Like what?
It's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
You need to chill acts a little bit.
If freaking us out,
you're acting kind of insane.
I think it's that time of the month is that time of the month.
If
you're talking about the time of the month when I do your performance review,
then you're right and you're screwed.
Sure.
Okay.
Hey guys,
this is Stephanie.
She's the newest member of our team.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Got a lot of this check.
What is this woman staring at?
It's like the Ann Taylor didn't try.
What is her problem?
I'm a female on the team.
You're placing me.
You should be threatened by me.
I love her suit.
Just can I have eyebrows?
Right.
Cool.
Hi,
I'm Stephanie.
Nice to meet you.
I can kind of be a sausage fest in here,
so I'm really happy to have another woman in the room.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Yes,
feminism.
That's fucking hard.
Can you give us a backstory on what led you to write feminist fight club and
also how you came up with all the amazing nomenclature in the book?
I really like puns.
Um,
as you will see,
um,
so as Melissa mentioned in my very long,
maybe two long bio,
uh,
I'm in a real life feminist fight club and a number of the women are,
are in the video,
but it's essentially a group of creatives.
We are journalists and writers and comics.
And we began meeting about a decade ago when we were just starting our careers.
We're all in New York City and most of us were in very white male dominated
fields and we were struggling.
We were frustrated.
We didn't know what we could be doing better to get ahead.
We often questioned whether what we were experiencing was actually sexism or
something more individual or personal.
And so we would gather about once a month in one of our members parents houses
because we couldn't put that many people in any of our tiny studio apartments
and we would just talk about what was going on for us at work and try to provide
support and offer each other advice on how we might try it to combat some of the
issues.
So the feminist fight club was real and back then the first rule of the fight
club was like in real fight club that you didn't talk about the club.
And that was funny,
but also for real reasons,
which were that a lot of the women in the group who were working at media
outlets and different organizations did fear that if word got out,
that they were in what was essentially a feminist consciousness raising group,
they would be either stigmatized or potentially penalized.
And so we didn't talk about the club,
but lo and behold,
here I am.
So the rules have changed.
And now the first rule of fight club is you must talk about the fight club.
Love it.
So at the beginning of the book,
you,
you kind of admit that the tone of the book is really light and you know,
it's very friendly and casual.
There are a lot of swear words.
Um,
so I'm just wondering,
you know,
and that's not to say that it's lacking in data or substance or seriousness of
subject.
So why did you decide to write in this tone?
Yeah,
I mean,
on the one hand it sort of is my tone.
Like I can't speak without swearing apparently.
Um,
and as a journalist,
I've sort of come up on the Internet.
So I wanted to speak to young people in their language,
which is also my language.
And I felt like I had been working on and writing about these issues for number
of years,
but I often was focused on the problem,
not on the solution.
And you know,
throughout my work with lean in and other outlets,
I always end up reading all of these academic studies that buried somewhere in
the,
you know,
page 19 there's like some little fight move or solution for how to combat a
mantra Reptar or a mansplainer,
but it's not used in that language.
And so I kept thinking to myself like,
if there was some way to just pull this stuff out and put it into a format that
was fun to read and they just double but also really practical and rooted in
research,
then it would provide a service that frankly,
I wish I had when I was starting my career.
And so,
you know,
I hope that there's something in this book for everyone,
but I want it to speak in a language that was light and you know,
sexism is not a fun topic,
but it can be fun to read about.
So I'm speaking about those tactics.
Those are sort of more of those individual or personal tactics,
um,
versus policy or institutional changes.
Why did you decide to focus on those individual level tactics?
Yeah,
I mean I think that ultimately like dealing with gender equity needs to come
from every level.
So it needs to happen on a,
a policy standpoint though currently in our leadership in this country,
I'm not very optimistic that that's going to happen.
It needs to come from a business and a company standpoint.
But I also think that I have felt in my career for many years that I was
frustrated and I didn't want to wait around for like HR policies or legal
policies or you know,
politics to solve these problems for me.
Not to mention that a lot of the forms of sexism we face today can't actually be
prosecuted in court or legalized for.
So what do you do?
Well,
there are actually ways that we can fight back against some of this stuff in our
everyday lives.
And it doesn't have to feel overwhelming.
Some of these are small things,
but we can do it on behalf of ourselves and we can do it on behalf of our fellow
women.
And so I wanted something that felt like I had agency that would allow me to
engage and try to work towards a larger,
more equal world and more equal workplace that I could do every day.
And so I certainly recognize the need for policy change and change from a
corporate level.
But like if you feel overwhelmed in your daily environment and you're constantly
being interrupted when you speak,
like there are things you can do to solve that.
So I want to talk a little bit more about those forms of sexism that you talk
about a lot in the book.
You call it death by a thousand cuts type of sexism.
Um,
it's the insidious casual,
politically correct,
even friendly sexism or racism that people experience.
Um,
and that is in contrast with an overt,
clear cut discrimination.
Like you said,
that has a legal definition.
So why is this kind of subtle sexism so much harder to report,
so much harder to fix and so much easier to dismiss?
I think because often we've internalized it and a lot of ways,
I know this is silicon valley,
we talk about unconscious bias a lot here.
I probably don't need to define that for the people in this room,
but you know,
once upon a time sexism was very overt and so I began my career at Newsweek as a
young writer and while I was there I started facing things like pitching an idea
and having it be turned down and then seeing it appear on the pages of the
magazine under a man's byline a few weeks later or feeling uncomfortable
speaking up in very white male dominated meetings or feeling like if I
negotiated for more money after finding out that a man with the same job title
and description was making thousands of dollars more than me,
that I would be perceived as pushy for wanting too much.
So it's the subtle things.
Whereas the generation prior,
while it wasn't Newsweek,
I found out about the women who had actually sued that company for gender
discrimination in the year 1970.
Um,
there's an Amazon series now about these women called the good girls revolt.
But at the time,
this was the first case of its kind and women who worked at Newsweek were told,
yes,
you will be hired,
you can do all of the job duties that a man can but you're not allowed to write.
We don't allow women to have fine lines.
And so at the end of the day they would hand over their notes and probably a cup
of coffee as well to a man who would get the credit and they sued and they were
able to sue because it was clear that this was discrimination.
They were saying outwardly that women are not allowed to right here and men are.
And so this prompted lawsuits at the New York Times and Time magazine and sports
illustrated like these women paved the way for female journalists.
And yet 40 years later here I was,
I was a writer.
I had the title to prove it.
And yet I was still facing some of these subtle things on a daily basis that
frankly,
like HR policies can't really solve for.
Like if you're the default note taker in a meeting or you're constantly being
interrupted or you're perceived as bitchy or Bossy,
when you make a command,
when that is what is expected ultimately of leaders,
what's HR going to do about it?
You know,
like the,
some of this stuff is internalized and for what it's worth,
it's not just internalized sexism that men possess.
It's women as well.
Yup.
You include a ton of data in,
in the book to back up the type of the type of sexism and discrimination that
you talk about.
So what sort of practical advice would you give to someone who wants to start
sharing this type of data with their teams?
Um,
to,
you know,
educate and empower them with,
with what we have after reading the book without coming off,
you know,
in that way.
Yeah,
totally.
Which will just point out like it sucks that we have to worry about that and we
shouldn't have to.
I'm so lucky for you.
There is a book,
um,
it's for sale on the back and you can just like leave it underneath bosses
doors,
put one in the ladies room who won in the men's room,
like whatever.
You can tear pages out of it,
like do your thing.
Um,
and then you can blame it on me.
So it doesn't have to view no,
but actually there is research showing that if you can present an idea on behalf
of the group rather than on behalf of yourself,
it's more likely to be accepted or taken in a way that you know,
doesn't make leave you feeling like you're being too demanding.
So I literally to help people to like print out studies and bring them up in
whatever the scenario is.
So okay.
Women are actually more likely to be interrupted than men twice as likely and
more so if they're a woman of color.
Obviously in workplaces where meetings are such a huge part of it and ideas are
such a huge part of it,
if you're being interrupted every time you speak,
you're not contributing ideas and you're not ultimately getting credit.
So,
okay.
How do you stop that?
Well,
you can like tell someone to shut up when they interrupt you.
I can tell someone that I want to hear what you have to say when you're being
interrupted so that it doesn't make you look like the bad guy,
bad guy.
I guess guys agender turn the bad Carson.
Um,
but also if you want it to casually bring up that women,
in fact data shows are twice as likely to be interrupted as men.
Like there's a study you can print out and there's a footnote in the back of the
book to do that.
And then it's putting it on data and research not on you being like too
emotional,
um,
or touchy and offended by a certain behavior.
So I say like whenever you can blame something on the data,
it's actually really effective.
And,
and part of the reason why the book is so reliant on it,
in addition to me not liking to just give personal advice cause I'm a journalist
and I'm trained to not do that.
But it means that you can always refer back to like a Harvard business review
study that can't be argued with.
Like these are all things we should do because they're the right thing to do.
But it can be hard to tell people that this is the right thing to do.
So you can tell them that they should do it because it's actually better for
business.
And companies with more gender equality have higher returns,
there are more profitable,
more collaborative.
And so there's all of these really datadriven reasons why it makes sense.
So in one of your previous comments,
you mentioned unconscious bias and unconscious bias training has seemingly taken
over silicon valley.
Can you share some of your thoughts on,
on implicit bias and what it means to,
um,
a,
become aware of it and B,
you know,
go through a training program to address it.
Yeah.
And so for what it's worth,
I did the,
I think it was MIT has an implicit bias test where you can take it and see if
you're bias and I,
yes,
I too am biased.
So I think it's very important to talk about this.
And the fact that,
you know,
implicit bias is a word that's being tossed around now.
And people know what it means.
It allows us to recognize that we all have it.
And I think that recognizing that we all have it is the first step toward
overcoming it.
I think that some of the problems with some of these training programs is that
they don't necessarily offer solutions.
And so I think while the first step in the very important step is recognizing
that we have bias and being able to notice it or check forward in the moment,
we have to also think about changing our behavior.
And so in the moment when you notice it,
like what can you do to stop yourself?
Or how can you point out when someone else is exhibiting bias?
Um,
and,
and for what it's worth,
you know,
I was in a meeting recently and a man and a woman walked in and I caught myself
in a moment of,
of bias,
assuming that the woman,
the assistant to the man,
and in fact,
she was his boss.
And this is like,
I wrote a whole book about this.
I talk about these issues all the time,
but it's like our brain takes these cognitive shortcuts that we have
internalized over.
I mean literally thousands and thousands of years of us being taught that it is
white men in charge and women who are supporting that.
And so I feel like if I have it like at,
we all haven't.
And so I think it's really important to talk about it.
And I think that there is no downside to these training programs.
But I also think that like,
especially here in Silicon Valley,
the idea of diversity and inclusion and bias trainings,
these are like words that are tossed around a lot and we can't just talk about
them.
We need to also have action associated.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Because only talking about them and learning about them tends to normalize them
and then no,
you know,
nothing gets done as a result.
Um,
so,
uh,
on the cover you,
there's an asterisk note for men.
So what is your message for men?
So for those that don't have the cover in front of them,
there's a little ass stuck right here.
And then it says book is 21% more expensive for men.
It's not really,
that would be illegal.
And actually it should not be 20% because we gained a penny.
Yay.
Um,
no,
my message is for men is ultimately that we need you and we cannot fight for
equality without men by our side.
They are so important to this battle.
And yet I try to use humor as a way into some of these issues.
And so the 21% supposed to be joke,
ha ha.
Um,
and,
and in fact I've seen it be effective in the sense that I,
I've seen men perusing the book and then seeing that Astrick and,
and sort of chuckling and then opening it up.
So hopefully that's a way in.
And I try to use humor as a way to talk about really tricky issues.
You know,
this stuff is hard and sometimes it's really uncomfortable.
And I think that sometimes men understandably feel uncomfortable engaging on
these topics or knowing how to be an ally.
And so I think it's so important to include them in the conversation and,
and you know,
let them know,
and not just men,
but women too,
that we are actually going to screw up sometimes.
Like we're not going to be perfect talking about this stuff all the time,
but like with a commitment to be better,
then we can screw up and correct for it.
And at the end of the day,
like men are half the population,
we cannot achieve it quality without their support.
Absolutely.
So speaking on the topic of inclusion,
I want to talk a little bit about intersectionality and just sort of get your,
your view on intersectionality and how it maybe has changed or evolved,
especially in our current climate.
Yeah.
So intersectionality for those who don't know the concept that feminism must be
interest sectional,
it must also look at the cross section,
the intersection of race,
of class,
of gender,
identity of sexuality,
and that really feminism is not feminism if it's not intersectional.
And that's certainly my belief.
This stuff needs to be incorporated and we need to be thinking about it all the
time.
I think that traditionally the mainstream women's movement,
at least the public part that you learn about in history books or you read about
in the press,
has not done a great job of taking intersectionality into account.
Like primarily the 1970s movement of Women's liberation was white.
And there were all sorts of really amazing subgroups,
women of color that were also rising up,
but they just weren't talked about as much.
So I do think that right now what we're seeing is a much more intersectional
view of all of this.
Like this is something that we're talking about regularly,
mainstream publications that,
you know,
don't assume any knowledge of feminism are using that word intersectionality.
The New York Times recently did it,
which was like a great thing for them,
I think.
Um,
and it's also important that some of the new emerging leaders we're seeing
talking about this,
the women of the women's march are of every race.
And so I think that it's so important because I think that ultimately like you
can't be a feminist if you don't also care about these issues.
Like feminism is intersectional.
So I want to talk about,
um,
one of the,
one of the pitfalls that,
that you mentioned in the book that really affects me.
Um,
so I can say I am an ever faithful and that means that I want to believe that
everything is fair,
that career and the workplace is a meritocracy.
So what advice would you give for people like me who still want to believe in
America,
meritocracy and behave as if we,
you know,
exist in one,
despite all the research that disproves that?
Um,
I would say that loyalty does not pay the bills.
and I think that as women,
we too often put our heads down and do good work and expect to be recognized for
it.
And that's not our fault.
Like,
typically it is harder for women to self promote and call attention to the good
work that they're doing.
Because when we do,
we're perceived as too braggy or we're just liked for it.
And so we sort of internalize these structures that have told us over,
you know,
years and years and years that we're supposed to be modest.
And so yes,
I would like to believe it's Ameritocracy too.
But I think that,
uh,
I'm too cynical for that.
And so any moment you can take to call attention to your accomplishments is not
a bad thing.
And if you feel uncomfortable doing it and list someone else.
There's a term I have and the book called Boast Bitch.
And this is a person who brags on your behalf and there's a real reason for
this.
It's because women are disliked when they brag about themselves.
But of course like we're working in office environments.
We need to draw attention to the work that we do.
So like you and I are both,
but just we have an unspoken or spoken agreement I bust for you.
You boast for me.
Like every time you do something great,
I s I send an email to our entire team and cc you on it and then you can look
completely humble.
I'm going to look like a great colleague and everyone gets credit.
So,
you know,
meritocracy,
like yes,
it would be great if that existed,
but I think that the numbers show us.
Otherwise,
I think we need to create a marketplace at Google for boast bitches.
You can sign up to be one or if people are uncomfortable with the word bitch,
you can call it like a boast bay,
whatever.
And for what it's worth in the sense that,
I mean most of which can be a man or a woman like and anyone can be a bust,
which is just someone who has your back.
Awesome.
Um,
another of the chapters that I thought was really powerful was the one on
negotiation and I especially loved the piece of advice is to,
to view your ask in shades of gray,
not black and white.
Um,
can you share your point of view on negotiation and how women and men approach
negotiation differently and therefore get different results?
There's a lot of research around the issue of negotiation and what the newer
research is finding is that women who do negate negotiate are often viewed as
aggressive or pushy and it makes them less likely to actually get the raise.
So all right,
like,
well,
how are you supposed to overcome that?
Like there's no real solution to that other than like keep asking and it will
become normalized and then we won't view a woman who asks us pushy or
aggressive.
But in addition to that,
women are often less likely to ask.
And so I know that in when I was starting my career,
I never,
I never asked,
I would've felt so incredibly lucky to have a job.
This was when I was at Newsweek,
um,
in the early two thousands,
and like journalism was imploding everywhere.
So I was in a way lucky to be employed,
but it caused me to,
to not ask.
And it wasn't until I realized as this other guy who I worked with,
with the same title was making many thousands of dollars more than me,
that I was like,
okay,
I have to go in and ask.
And,
and so what I did is I tried to be very data driven about it.
Like I didn't want to go in and tell them that I felt I deserved it or that I
needed to pay off my student loans.
I want it to come in with a list of statistics about the work that I'd done.
So like I added up every possible conceivable statistic you could find in a
field like journalism where there's not really metrics but to things like page
views on articles,
number of articles written,
um,
perceived value of like press hits that I'd done on television.
Um,
what else?
Like anything else I could find.
And I in fact then wrote it up like a buzzfeed listicle,
top 10 lists,
like why you should give Jessica vented arrays.
Um,
and I went in and I tried to express this and naturally I was like stuttering
and stumbling over my words.
And bright red,
but then I followed up with the email.
So I think it's important to be really data focused and data driven.
I think it's important to know that women do struggle with this and they're
often penalized more so than men.
But truly the way that we're going to make this equal is by continuing to ask
and,
and I think that what companies can do as well as well as look at salary parody.
I think Google is doing something around this,
but comparing is there a gap in your company between men and women and if there
is solving for it.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's great advice.
Thank you.
Um,
so the,
your feminist fight club is largely outside of work,
um,
but obviously made up of professional women,
but inside of the workplace,
um,
you know,
would you,
would you recommend a feminist fight club,
uh,
made up of,
of colleagues and,
yeah.
Um,
what do you think are some of the strengths and some of the limitations of that
sort of environment taking place at work?
Yeah,
I mean anyone can form a feminist fight club and there's a guide at the back of
the book on how to do so,
which basically is like do whatever you want.
Um,
and many people in fact have forms of feminist fight clubs like we called ours
that and we also had a top secret name that I cannot reveal.
Um,
but you know,
we thought it was important for our group to have a mix of women in creative
industries but not all in the same field because we wanted to have a diversity
of voices.
And so we sort of hand picked based on that.
But a lot of it was also random.
Like I ended up there through a mentor whose daughter was in it and a lot of it
just came organically.
But I think the talking about these issues at work can be so important.
Like lean in circles are now in companies all over the world and I think it's
been really effective to talk about them with colleagues.
And so forming a feminist fight club.
Yeah.
Like basically by being here,
you are all members of the feminist fight club.
Welcome,
lifelong membership.
There's no dues like you're in.
Um,
but you can also form smaller groups.
And I don't know,
for me like having a group of women who I knew were unconditionally supportive
and I could always turn to if I had a problem,
has truly helped me grow in many ways throughout my career and even my personal
life.
And I think there's no downside to it.
I think that we need to help each other.
The third rule of the new feminist fight club is we fight patriarchy,
not each other.
So the idea of treating other women as allies,
not as enemies,
we don't need to be competitive.
We are more powerful together.
We can lift one another up.
One of the pieces or one of the chapters that contained a ton of great advice
was what would Josh do?
And this was sort of advice to think like Josh,
who's a male colleague with Chutzpah,
meaning,
you know,
shameless audacity not to be confused with utter bullshit.
So I'm just wondering,
first of all,
how do you distinguish between those two?
Because I think,
you know,
I struggled with that chapter because you know,
some of the advice felt like would I be going against what is sort of natural to
me and how much sort of do I need to work on that?
So yes,
the chapter's called WWJD Wa the other Jay.
Well with Josh,
do you carry yourself with the confidence of a mediocre white man?
And Josh in fact is the real,
is harder than it sounds.
It's not named Josh and he's a lovely individual and a good friend of mine.
But we used to share a wall at Newsweek.
We sat next to each other and so I got to sort of observe him in all scenarios.
And we had similar jobs except that like every time there was a meeting I would
be like in my office with the door closed.
This was back when people had offices.
Um,
I'll never have an office again now I just work in my bed.
But I would be like,
you know,
studying up for a pitch meeting,
like determined to have every fact,
right.
So nervous being so prepared.
And he would be like in his office with his feet up on the desk,
just like ready to go in and bullshit his way through.
And in his case he was also very smart.
So his bullshit was educated bullshit.
But what the research shows is that actually we mistake sometimes confidence for
competence,
right?
And so the way that he was delivering it with such confidence was almost as
effective as my really studied,
but unconfident pitches as well.
And so it allowed me to observe him.
And so throughout the chapter I advise,
you know,
asking yourself in various scenarios WWJD or ww MD,
what would a man do?
Not so that women can start mimicking bay male behavior,
but because we often underestimate ourselves.
And so I know that for me in a scenario where I was feeling nervous or wasn't
sure how to go about something,
I would ask myself what would Josh do?
And then I would end up somewhere in the middle like,
Joshua do this.
I would naturally do this,
I would end up here.
And so often we underestimate ourselves or you know,
we have faced imposture syndrome where we don't feel like we deserve to be there
or belong.
And so a little bragging like actually may get us to the point where we should
be,
where we're not underestimating our abilities in our accomplishments.
So yeah,
I,
I proudly carry myself with the confidence of a mediocre white.
I love it.
Um,
so last question.
You know,
you,
you sort of described yourself as a cynic,
but I'm holding out hope that you're still hopeful and so I'm wondering how,
how do you remain hopeful and humorous and encouraged when,
when,
you know,
digging into this research that's really sort of challenging to confront,
um,
and ran in what's happening in the world?
Yeah.
Um,
yes.
Uh,
so I try to have a sense of humor about it.
Like if I,
if I couldn't laugh about some of this stuff,
I think I would just be depressed.
Yeah.
So I still try to find humor in some of these things.
Feminists in fact,
are really funny.
Um,
we do have senses of humor like that.
There's a joke,
how many feminists does it take to screw in a light bulb?
And then it's like,
that's not funny.
But actually it is funny,
I think anyway,
like we laugh about this stuff.
It's serious.
Yes,
it's serious.
But we can laugh and I also find a lot of hope in the younger generation.
Yeah.
Like a lot of the women that I work with and,
and talk to you for stories and who helped me on feminist fight club,
social media,
our college women and college men and the way that they talk about and think
about these issues is so much further along than I was at their age.
Like the way that they think about,
they approach this intersectionally and the hope that they have.
There's a study that came out recently about how Gen z and younger millennials
are actually much more hopeful than the rest of us.
So like,
you know,
look to the youth.
The kids are all right.
Um,
and,
and so I go to them whenever I needed a dose of bringing me up.
I love that.
Thank you.
So now I want to open it up to questions from the audience.
And Lizzie has a microphone.
Um,
so we were just talking about this before.
Every now and then something happens where a man does something that's well
intentioned but tone deaf.
So recently we got an email from some men inviting us to a mixer for women.
And I thought,
why are the men inviting us to this?
Why is there not a woman throwing the mixer and why are the men even part of it?
And so I asked my boss like this is pretty tone deaf in his response was yes,
but it was well intentioned.
How do you respond to that?
Because I feel like a message could maybe should get to the men who sent it,
but it was well intentioned.
And so why do we want to bring it up?
I mean,
I would say that you have to call these things out.
Like you know,
you don't have to be a bitch calling this stuff out,
like or be perceived as a bitch.
It's important to talk about it.
And so if it is tone deaf,
then he should let them know and so I don't know it all,
you know so much of this stuff is so individual.
It depends on your power within the organization.
Is this person your boss?
Like do you feel comfortable speaking up?
And I always fall back on if it's not just you,
if it's a number of women part of that group who are asking for something to
happen,
then not any individual can be singled out and so perhaps the response would be
for multiple of you to go back and say,
I totally understand and I appreciate you passing this information along or
whatever.
Maybe because yeah,
a lot of this is tone deafness and some and we make mistakes but no one's going
to learn if they don't know that there are tone deaf and so the message needs to
make it back to those people.
I think my question is around the,
that have sort of played out at Uber,
which have become pretty well known,
I think,
especially here in Silicon Valley over the last few weeks.
And I think obviously that was an extreme case that the writer sort of talked
about and in her article on medium.
But I think for a lot of us that work in Silicon Valley's women were like,
of course these subtle daily acts of sexism happen every day.
Like why is this so surprising to people?
Um,
but I think one thing that made me start thinking was one of the followup
articles was talking about how Uber's performance system is a bell curve and how
they have five performance buckets and it sort of encourages people to undercut
their,
their teammates.
Um,
or because of things like imposter syndrome,
it,
you know,
encourages the men to shine and the women not to shine.
And then,
you know,
I think that their performance system is probably directly modeled after
Google's or it's very,
very similar from what it sounds like.
So my question to you is like,
have you read anything about that?
Or have you thought about that or do you have any sort of date,
and I haven't read it yet,
but I'm excited too.
But data that sort of supports this idea of like performance and the best ways
to measure that.
So it's not a systemic problem for men versus women succeeding in a company.
Right.
Well I think that one very important thing is setting really clear criteria for
success.
So lean in and Mckinsey put out this study every year of women in the workplace
and this past one they,
they found that something like 78% of companies said that they support gender
equality or the it was the employee is saying that they believe their CEOs
really supported gender equality and yet like 50% of the managers in those
companies didn't actually know what to do.
And then only 38% of those companies actually set clear criteria for things like
hiring.
And what we know is that at least as it pertains to hiring,
but I imagine it pertains to performance reviews as well.
Women are often judged based on their past performance and men are judged based
on their potential.
So literally like we have to have a line item on our resume and looking at a man
and you're like,
oh,
he could do it.
Like I can see him as a future leader.
And oftentimes if people seeing those people as future leaders are also men.
And so,
you know,
the reality is it's sometimes easier to see someone who looks like you rise up.
So what can you do?
Well,
if you have very clear criteria and you know that that's existing,
then you can set metrics for it and you can make sure that you're not hiring or,
or reviewing based on what you think a person's potential may be.
Um,
I don't know specifically what companies have done to try to,
I don't know,
I guess solve for that bell curve,
but I have to think that having more women in leadership to talk about these
things,
I mean,
it's like the same reason why we were talking about earlier.
Our microphones don't clip onto the back of it just because they were made by
men and they were made for men.
And so you see this across the board,
um,
in small things and large things.
And if women are involved in the decision making process about how people are
judged or about how whatever this may be in this case,
then I think that they can elevate some of these,
these issues.
Um,
so that's not a perfect solution on how to do it.
But I think like all of this stuff is so interconnected and until half of the
leaders are women,
like we will continue to have these problems.
But I also think it's important that people are speaking out and talking about
it.
Like that woman writing that piece that went completely viral has sparked a
conversation that yes,
I totally agree.
Many of us were like,
yeah,
Duh.
Like obviously this is happening,
we know this,
but it appears that a lot of people didn't know it and it's getting mainstream
press attention now,
which is a good thing.
And you know,
we're obviously under scrutiny to change some of its policies.
And so I think that,
or I hope that we'll see a ripple effect there,
but oftentimes it does take someone speaking out and going out on a limb,
which is where I go back to power in numbers.
Like she wasn't working at the company anymore,
so she felt comfortable speaking out.
But for those who are inside,
sometimes it helps to band together and approach it as a group because you can't
be penalized.
You're more powerful.
And if you're experiencing something,
probably someone else's to any resources to share about language,
to pushback on disempowering praise.
I recently got,
she's a smart cookie on a project I'm leading.
I have a phd in neuroscience and eight years of industry experience.
I am not a cookie.
I am an expert.
Any advice,
um,
call it out like you're yeah,
you're not,
I call that the undermine her.
Um,
the person who's like,
great job Kiddo,
or thank you honey or cookie,
like all of those little language pieces that are so tiny.
But there's so undermining.
Like,
if you're standing there and your team sees you being called a cookie,
but some other leader,
like are they going to respect you?
So I think calling it out,
sometimes we may have to take that person aside and be like,
hey,
we're all in this for the same thing.
I think it actually benefits you for,
for our team to see me as a leader.
And when you call me cookie,
um,
it undermines my authority.
So calling out the behavior.
Um,
and you know,
the,
I think that we're being more cognizant these days of speech patterns.
So you know,
from things like that too,
the way that so much of our language is his gender.
Like I've started,
um,
trying find an alternative when I say you guys.
Um,
but even things like there's a,
there's a dictionary in the book,
an a to z.
It's a how,
not to be a dictionary
guide to nonsexist language,
but like things that I had never realized,
like the words Seminole,
it comes from seaman.
Like that is a male derived term and that is what we use to describe great
works.
Right?
And so there's stuff is so,
so ingrained into every tiny bit of our culture and sometimes it's a matter of
calling it out when we see it because people do not even realize it.
Yup.
And for what it's worth,
like would you call a man cookie?
No.
Like you can pretty much apply that question to anything.
Like would I view her as bossy if she were a man?
Probably not.
So asking that question as well,
trying to formulate this question.
I guess this is about,
um,
any lessons learned from male allies and I guess I'm seeing this through the
lens of anxiety.
You know,
anxiety is important because it pushes people to change,
but it can also prompt a backlash.
And I liked the language that you used about,
hey,
you know,
I'm,
I'm actually trying to be helpful to us.
So just any thoughts that you have?
Again,
like things that you feel like have been successful in sort of recruiting allies
are getting mindshift in allies to,
to see common cause,
anything like that?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think just talking more openly is really step one because I think we're
hesitant to talk about these issues and we're fearful that we're going to screw
up.
And you know,
I wrote a whole book that has language like mansplaining and mantra option and
broke appropriation everywhere and on some level that can make men feel
targeted.
Um,
I'm also trying to use it as a way to have humor to open up some of these
issues,
but I think we have to get over our fears about talking about it and just
discuss more openly so that the stigma goes away.
A followup to that is,
um,
you know,
basically they have this notion of sort of lowering the cost for screwing up.
I mean,
I guess it's proportional to the screw up.
Like in some ways we'd have to raise the cost,
but,
but for those,
uh,
like maybe micro aggressions should have a Mike Rowe price.
Um,
and it's basically like,
look,
you know,
like I appreciate that we're all working together and like making it less like,
um,
you know,
I read an article that was like,
like,
um,
basically implicit bias is the new way to say that you're a racist.
And the person was just like,
oh,
I'm not a racist.
And it's like,
no.
Oh my God.
It's the exact opposite.
It's trying to say we all,
because of us as primates,
we have these cognitive shortcuts.
It's meant to know,
you know,
to say,
look,
we're,
you're in good company,
but it's having kind of the opposite effect.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I try to talk about the ways that I've screwed up frequently as a way to
let my audience or whomever it may be know that like if I'm doing it to them,
we're all doing it and it's okay.
And so maybe one way to approach it,
at least I'm trying to get other people on your side is by beginning with
something that you've done that you realized and then maybe they won't feel
attacked.
I mean,
it's like we shouldn't have to dance around this issue and walk on eggshells.
But the reality is that like we work in office environments and we want to be
respectful and we don't want people to feel attacked or offended.
And I think that the reality is that most men really do want to help and they
want to be allies.
And I believe that,
but it's also backed in sorts,
all sorts of data.
And especially young men,
like they want gender equality,
they want equal relationships.
But this is like for hundreds and hundreds of years,
men have run shit.
And so there is a learning curve.
Like it does take some time to overcome some of these issues.
So yeah,
I think talking about a way that you've experienced it as one way and talking
about things in groups so that one person doesn't feel attacked.
Um,
but also just knowing that like sometimes uncomfortable stuff is going to come
up,
but we can still have productive conversations about it.
Yeah.
Just to a couple of questions that we'll try to keep short.
What do we do about the fact that the f word of feminism turned some people off
immediately?
And how do we get those people back into the conversation hopefully and about,
I'll do that one first.
Um,
so I really do think that the stigma around the word feminism is changing.
I think that celebrities have had a lot to do with this.
In fact,
like seeing Beyonce on stage at the Vma is defining the word.
Um,
that's,
that's like bigger than any other feminist could ever accomplish.
So I think that the stigma is going away.
I also think that continuing to talk about what the definition of feminism
actually is,
it means that you as a person that believes in gender equality between the
sexes,
and that's like the most benign thing ever.
Like who's going to say they're anti that?
So I think that it's going away.
I also think am of the belief that like if you don't want to call yourself a
feminist,
but you believe in these things and you're going to fight for them,
like fine,
that's better than nothing.
And so whether you call yourself a feminist or not,
I think it's about working towards equality.
And for what it's worth.
Like when I was pitching this book in the beginning,
which was a couple of years ago,
I said to my mail agent,
do you think we should call this lady fight club because people are going to be
so offended by the word feminist.
And you know,
I'm coming from a mainstream news background.
I didn't want to go with a niche feminist press.
I wanted this book to reach the masses.
And he to his credit was like,
no,
feminist is a stronger title.
We're going to go out with that.
And so we did.
And I was sort of wary.
I was nervous about what would happen.
And to my surprise,
um,
you know,
we had bids from a dozen different mainstream publishers,
not niche feminist press's.
And so that to me was very encouraging.
And I think that that was still two years ago.
I think that the word has become,
um,
more mainstream since then.
But there will always be arguments about the word feminism.
Like for so long this is occurred.
And I don't know,
every decade or so there's like a conversation around should we rebrand feminist
and like should we call it something else?
And I don't think that's gonna happen,
but you know,
if you're willing to wear the,
the title proudly I say like do it loud
and then just around intersectionality,
um,
I'm off.
I feel like I'm often fearful that I've heard people in other minority groups
who are also women complain that they feel like their voices are not heard.
What advice do you have for white women or anyone who wants to make sure that
they're supporting and raising up those voices rather than potentially
accidentally talking over them or shutting them out of the conversation?
I think like first of all,
try not to be defensive.
Um,
because I see this happen online so much where like white women are called out
for some of their behavior and probably much in the same way that men feel
attacked at work.
The immediate response is like defensiveness.
And I think that we need to listen more.
Like we need to listen more.
We need to respect that these voices have been marginalized for years and years
and years.
So even if we may not think in a particular moment that we are drawing them out,
like we have long had a voice,
not as much of a voices as men but a voice and,
and there was a really long history of racism in the,
in the women's movement.
And so I think yeah,
we have to,
we have to like be okay with screwing up and be okay with being called out for
it and like try to correct the behavior and move on.
I think you sort of addressed this,
but let's go directly to it.
Again,
one of the senior leaders on my team has recently received a bit of flack for
using guys too often as a blanket term when addressing a mixed gender group.
It doesn't bother me yet.
When someone uses ladies to email only admins,
it does.
What's your take on sensitivities like that?
I think we need to just right here,
right now come up with a better term for guys.
Like y'all s feels weird to me folks.
Okay.
Yes.
So maybe,
maybe we have solved this right here.
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you to the Unicorn in the room.
One of Tim,
you all?
Yeah,
I mean
it's so progressive.
Yeah.
I think that this stuff is like so entrenched in our language and yeah,
I need all of you to focus this site.
You know,
what are,
you know,
um,
yeah,
I mean I need to get more comfortable with folks.
Yeah.
Where we are,
we come up with anywhere humans,
basically all language a census if you really get down to it.
Oh,
about a year ago I had an incident with a friend,
like a good friend who uh,
was talking about,
um,
like the,
the efforts going on for hiring diverse people.
And this is a very respectful person that I am on good terms with.
But he said,
uh,
you know,
that the,
to use his words,
and I still remember this,
the pendulum has swung too far and like people are being hurt by like these
efforts.
Like basically good people are not being hired because like something something
good.
We're looking for diverse candidates,
implying the woman thing.
And I dunno,
like I didn't know how to respond at the time,
which was going to be like not,
I didn't,
I didn't want to like say blah blah blah feminism there.
I did want to say that I wanted to say that,
but I also just,
it's not going to solve the problem and I don't know how to address it.
Advice please.
Yeah.
And I feel like,
feel free to chime in if anyone else has advice to,
um,
well when,
as you were saying that I wanted to do like Rah Rah,
Rah feminist,
some things too for the record.
I mean it's tricky.
It's like,
yeah,
well welcome to like history where these people have been marginalized and not
hired for years and years and years and we have to correct for that somehow.
But I think that also,
I don't know,
I mean throwing the numbers back in that person's face,
like probably they're referencing a team or a company that is still a majority
white male,
even if this person feels that the pendulum has swung too far and then
potentially I'm making note of the fact that actually it's a better for the
company to have a more diverse team and like listing off all those stats about
how teams with more diversity or more collaborative and more successful and
companies with more women on the board have higher returns and even things like
in a room,
in a meeting where there are at least 25% women,
which is what social science calls the point of critical mass.
Then those women in the room will a feel more comfortable speaking up and be
what they are saying,
we'll actually be hurt more.
It's sort of this point where we stopped viewing that 25% as a minority group or
a speaking on behalf of women or on behalf of their race and just view them as
experts who are in the room.
So that's not a perfect answer,
but trying to remind that person.
Does anyone else want to chime in with their thoughts?
Um,
so moving on to kind of a different note,
you brought up imposter syndrome,
which I think a lot of people in this room can identify with,
myself included.
Um,
you know,
it,
you know that you're good at your job,
logically,
you,
you understand that you do a good job every day and like an email comes in on
Friday afternoon with your manager asking to meet with you and you like panic,
right?
Because you're like,
oh,
I'm totally in trouble.
Like there's no doubt.
Yeah,
I'm totally getting fired.
In fact,
I'll just quit.
Right,
exactly.
Like maybe I'll just put on Friday afternoon so I don't have to have anxiety all
weekend about it.
What are your tips for dealing with that and trying to kind of like deal with
the internalized sense of like,
I'm a failure or I'm going to be a failure or it should be a failure.
Right,
right.
I think first like knowing that you are not the only one to feel this way.
Like imposter syndrome,
this sense that you don't belong,
that you don't deserve to be there,
that you're not good at your job.
This disproportionately statistically affects women and minorities.
So LGBT,
racial minorities and oftentimes it's because those groups of people have this
added pressure of accomplishing firsts or needing to not fuck up because
there'll be judged on behalf of their gender or their race if they do.
So first off,
knowing that like literally I power pose before I go onstage and I was speaking
at a law firm on Monday and it was a paid gig and I was like,
why?
Literally,
why are these people paying me?
Like I should pay them?
Like I can't believe.
And it was like a welfare and I was like,
I don't just serve this knife.
So okay,
so we all experience it so you're not alone.
Second,
you can try to trick your brain and this has been found to be effective so that
instead of focusing on how you feel,
you focus it on the issue of imposter syndrome.
Like,
it's not me.
It's the imposter syndrome talking and literally like saying that in the mirror
has been proven to be effective and trying to overcome it because it makes it an
issue,
not your issue.
I also think that having friends and allies and members of your feminist fight
club or whomever it is to remind you that like,
you're not getting fired.
You don't suck.
It's going to be okay.
I'm like,
I know that you're good at what you do.
Can,
you know,
be like the voice that you need inside your head to support you.
There's other things you can do to like power posing or there's a,
there's a list of them in the book.
But I think that like,
remembering that,
you know,
Sheryl Sandberg says she felt like a fraud and Meryl Streep,
the woman with the most Oscars has said that every time she wins an award,
she thinks they must have made a mistake.
And so it's,
it's all of us.
Um,
and even some of the world's most famous and successful people.
Thank you all so much for your [inaudible].
Thank you.